have you seen like pictures of your
parents and stuff like that when they
were young yeah and stuff yeah I love
that resource video of why do you your
parents even look old in their younger
pictures yeah yeah that's true I haven't
seen that one well think about it like
when you see pictures of your parents
when they're young they look old still
right they look old even when they're
like 20. or when you look at pictures of
like 19 what was like high school kids
in the 70s they look old they look older
for some reason than high school kids
today think about it and it's and yeah
and it's this weird like cycle I mean
obviously there's a resource video but
like it's like weird psychological
trick that happens of like because it's
from an older time yeah you initially
condition yourself to look at that and
be like that is an older person yeah
from before but they still look older
because your only image of that is this
thing is old well like also what I find
would what I'm going to find interesting
going forward is that
um
the world was just never as well
documented as it is now doesn't it look
older
that's high school they don't they don't
look like high schoolers right yeah like
this dude I mean doesn't look like a
high school
I think I think it looks oh just because
of the just because of the aesthetic
right
yeah but that's what I'm saying Okay
okay then I get it because I I look back
right I think back and I see photos like
that and it just feels old because I
can't imagine living in that time zone
because you have like the serpia
filter everyone looks video you mean
sorry
it looks like it's going through like a
sepia filter everyone looks different
the haircut's different and I can't
imagine it being in like 4K HD you know
what I mean right like I I can't like I
can't imagine looking around and being
like oh this is what it looks like in
normal colors in 4K HD and like
that right right which is why when I see
like have you ever seen like old videos
that have been remastered with like
modern colors yeah yeah that freaks me
out so much right yeah it's like that um
there's videos that where it's like some
One filmed like Japan in like 1910 yes
I've seen that and then they just but
it's 4K yeah recolored remastered it's
cool and it freaks me out because I'm
like people are freaked out like what
the is that thing yeah there's that
camera because you look at this video of
like I think there's like one of like
Kyoto in like the 1890s or something
yeah and it's just weird to think like
oh every single person in this video is
not here anymore yeah and that's like
terrifying it's so weird to think you'll
still say that yeah it's so weird
they're characters okay
the whole NPC they're all NPCs everyone
is a history MP3 that only exists in the
books okay
yeah it's it's so like it's just so
fascinating I had that thought with like
World War II right like yeah growing up
oh yeah you had like uh grandparents and
stuff in here and then now it's slowly
getting to the point where like in a few
years or you know in like 10 something
years whatever it's like the there's
gonna be so little World War II um
survivors and within like 20 30 years
there'll be no World War II yeah that's
weird to think about yeah growing up you
you'd always see them on like TV and
they would talk about it and you're like
this is like a thing yeah and then now
there's nobody who remembers it nobody
who was there yeah you can recount that
time period yeah like this extremely
important historical event when nobody
was alive for it yeah like that's so
weird going from having people alive to
it to then not having people alive like
especially in our time right because
obviously we can speculate what the
Romans were like and stuff but no one in
our time knows anyone who was ever alive
doing that you know what I mean like
weird thinking that that's it's like and
and it's like you know that's how that's
is always I always find that there's
this disconnect with history right where
you know it happens you you know that
these people existed but they they also
just kind of feels feel like characters
in the book yeah it's also cool having
this much documentation right because
like I think the older the history is
the more scarce options we have to
figure out exactly right so we have to
like fill in the pieces ourselves for
sure for sure but like what I find
interesting is that I have this image of
my parents when they were like younger
right and you have like I have like
stories that I've heard from like uncles
and aunties and some old pictures but at
the end of the day it's still just an
image of what they were like I don't
actually know what they were like you
know
um our kids are gonna our kids are
gonna have like every single like
they're gonna have like every argument
we've had about bone and chicken and
like if if my kid doesn't like chicken
wings he's gonna know why oh my
dad how old is your how old is your
grandma
oh my grandma on my dad's side is around
97. okay okay this is a weird thing
right your grandma that is 97 is like an
age-wise was is closer to like the
Victorian area than like today yeah from
the moment she was born right isn't that
weird to think that Victoria that we
think of that really quirky time like
weird where they were doing
weird they were playing like
asbestos in their wallpaper yeah and
everything it's like you know it's just
weird to think there are people who are
alive today who are old who are closer
to these really far-off periods in
history that we think is far off because
we're born now yeah we think 150 years
ago that's crazy you know what I mean
yeah um like also there was a great
video where it was like a like 1960s or
50s this woman who was like 90. and she
was recounting stories of the Victorian
period because obviously at that time it
was still you know it was still around
yeah
right yeah weird it's just so strange
geez that's yeah there's videos of these
people talking about those times so
strange yeah and it's weird like you
know going back to like ancient history
is weird to think
we can't we can't really process in in
our minds just how old like ancient
Egypt was you know yeah because you get
to a point in history and you think oh
it's all like around the same period
it's all like Roman Roman history Greek
history ancient you know ancient
Egyptian history so it's all the same
because it's all history but like it's
isn't it like the ancient Egyptians were
as all to the Romans as the Romans are
to us yeah something along those like
that like some great civilization make
it feel like it's all one blur yeah when
you actually look at the time between
like whoa yeah I think yeah because I
think I saw something similar whereas
like it was a lot like that but like say
with like the dinosaurs right of like I
think it's something like in our heads
we think like Tyrannosaurus Rex and
stegosaurus are just like yeah they were
around the same time like it's it's you
know it's all during the dinosaur era
yeah but in actuality I think between
the stegosaurus and the Tyrannosaurus
Rex there's like 400 million years oh no
we're uh humanity is a footnote
compared to how long the dinosaurs yeah
ruled the world but it's just so crazy
to think that it's like yeah they're the
same thing they're around the same time
and it's just not even like we like to
think that we're better like ah look at
these dumb animals they got wiped out by
media bro we've like hardly
we've barely lived the amount of like we
have been we live have lived a fraction
of the time they have Ruled the Earth
yeah and then all it took was like one
day and they're like gone you
know it's it's because they didn't get
along we wiped out more of us than
anyone else all right
no meteor can take that away from yeah
that's retails way more of us than that
dumb meteor ever would have all
right there's just four flexing on the
meteorite we are the best at killing us
yeah without now
no one is better than us that's why I
was smart just to kid however if
the ants decided to have an uprising we
would be oh absolutely absolutely
if the answer decided they have had
enough of being in the ground if the
insect World decide
do you know something weird I've been
doing in the holidays are you clapping
hands
um I haven't been collecting out okay
thank God I would have been this is who
did not want to get it I'm not mailing
don't worry about that please do not
start climbing ants I've been I've been
reading a book
like in 2023 like like a book book like
wow words like not not even like a light
novel like a heavy like no pictures like
no pictures wow it's just a heavy novel
so yeah
I've been reading this uh sci-fi uh
sci-fi novel called children children of
time you ever heard of this book
it's I but maybe you have maybe you
haven't I don't know I just uh I I
um I know you haven't you don't read I
hear what people talking about oh okay
oh my God what are those funny things
yeah I mean it's I've heard of a book
before you know those it's it's like
I've read about a book yeah it's a
fascinating read uh because I I heard
something I heard something about the
book that kind of like piqued my
curiosity uh because it explores the
idea of like what
what aliens actually are and what's
Evolution actually is right so uh the
premise the premise of this book right
is Humanity at the beginning of Like A
Flat Earth a conspiracy theory yeah what
is evolution let's break it down let's
pray let's break it down so it it poses
this question so it's the book is set in
like the Far Far Future where humanity
is like an advanced race or something
like that and there's this one person
who just goes let's let's do an epic
experiment
um let's try and give monkeys these
virus this virus that speeds up
Evolution put them on a planet and see
what happens okay and then I one day and
then eventually when they become as
smart as us I will come down and be
their new Gods right okay
um but unfortunately sorry Connor the
the plan goes wrong all the monkeys dies
uh but what happens instead is that
spiders instead get infected by this
virus all right that just kind of like
just speeds up evolution
and um
and uh speeds up Evolution and knowledge
basically like that um so what happens
is it follows why spiders man
that's like the worst people to get
events but that's that's why spiders
because when we think of what is alien
to us like what is more alien to us and
un understandable than spiders and it's
fascinating to think for one it may like
it cemented the realization that if
aliens exist there's no way we'd
be able to communicate with them or like
or like have any resemblance to us
whatsoever
um because it really like it it follows
this spider civilization that emerges
from like I guess their Stone Age to
their Modern Age right and it shows how
different basically everything in their
civilization would be
um from like human civilization
um just based on what spiders are so
like a great example is it of this is
like Midway through the book slight
spoilers but it's only like a small
scene Midway through the book uh one of
the advanced humans crash land on this
planet right
um and the spiders kind of like they
they take they they take this human in
and they start studying this human
um and they come to the conclusion that
humans must be dumb man because
there's no there's no way that spot that
there's no way that it can communicate
right um because spider the way spiders
communicate is they don't have ears they
communicate through vibrations yeah so
they form this communication system with
vibrations through their webs to
communicate complex ideas to each other
and there's humans use this human who is
barking
voice like Sound Vibrations to them
they're like nah there's there's no way
any animal would use sound as a
vibration like medium that's that's dumb
why would people do that yeah and
there's no way that any animal would any
animal would evolve
um an orifice that they use to
communicate and also ingest food that
just seems sub-optimal why would any why
would I know any animals do that and the
spiders come to the conclusion that
humans are these uh dumb animals that
have not like reached Evolution
everything like that and it's just
there's so much about this book that
like opens your mind and like makes you
rethink what is it about like our
society and our civilization that as
that is based on us basically coming
from monkeys and everything like
that so basically if ants do like
decides do an uprising it's probably
going to be a different kind of
Uprising than anything that we can
imagine and everything like that
I don't know like I think it's easy to
think that Evolution just stops because
you're like everything I get it now I
understand how every animal is and how
we are but obviously it's kept it's been
going on for millions of years and it'll
probably keep on going yeah people will
get like Tails I'll be sick we
might grow another arm who knows
who knows is where humanity is going to
be in like millions and millions of
years hopefully you're not around if we
live as long as if we live as long as
the dinosaurs that would be pretty
interesting I'd like to think the
spiders are watching me and they're like
what is he doing it's just me watching
like
damn
this must be a complicated human ritual
[Laughter]
yeah it's just like that Meme where it's
just like you know people look back on
the memes and they try to study like
low-cap images or something I
was like this must have been some
ancient religious text or something like
that do you think that actually happened
with like the agents with our own yeah
yeah yeah yeah we've I swear they've
been studied the cases where we thought
it was something and we were so wrong
multiple times because obviously you get
more information and you you know the
world's become more connected and it's
you know a lot of information that we
had in English was based off like wrong
accounts and also sources that weren't
really great and so now we can we can
translate and stuff so as much better
yeah no no not that we're doing right
now could you imagine if like some
archeology just was just like stunning
like ancient Egyptian like hieroglyphs
that can be like oh we still haven't
like uncovered what this meaningful
message must be because they left it on
this wall and then you you know you go
back four thousand years and this is
just she's just like
it's just some alarms
oh we'll get to bend and they're like
what are these strange golden like M
Signs they've put everywhere they seem
to be there must be the cult of M they
should be in every place in Mass she was
on today what is this a ritual or it's
been some ancient religion yeah in a
really crucial part to the human's
existence
you know what I mean we found sir we
found more golden M's lying around what
could it mean there's so many of them
what could it mean there's so many in
this one continent in America there
seems to be a density of these oh my god
oh man it's uh
yeah it would be interesting to think
it's like a sick book though
they should make that into an anime
they're not okay honestly it's like if
you if if you like me it kind of sounds
like terraformers but less anime
terraformers if it was smart yeah it's
terraformers if it like there's there's
so many interesting ideas like
eventually the spiders
um learn how to make computers but they
learn how to make computers via
programming like ant programming like
programming ants off those
which I'm just like I never thought
about it like that but if you could
learn to program ants videos because
ants ants have like a real ants have a
set of programming right it's you think
about a normal Ant and the stupid as
but somehow ant colonies if you
study ant colonies they're able to do
some incredible things dumb
individuals smart together we should
make ant AI
or would it be real intelligence no AI
stands for ant intelligence
dude when the ants see what we did to
them they're gonna be pissed they see
all these tick tocks people owning them
bro it's over dude it's over
oh my God it's like I'm sorry melon this
uh she's the first one she's the first
piece
already like all the pesticides right
they already evolve to kind of be Beyond
it and we're constantly tracing the next
one yeah we'll get to the point where
using this pesticide is just not
feasible because it's so dangerous to us
yeah